Speaking on Ukrainian state television, President
Petro Poroshenko said he turned to Berlin
after the Kremlin failed to respond to his
request for dialogue.
"Immediately at night, I ordered a phone conversation
with the President of Russia Putin.
We did not receive response and I had to address
to the German Chancellor so that she can talk
to Putin on immediate release of Ukrainian
servicemen and Ukrainian ships."
Poroshenko also said the authorities would
take all necessary steps to release the Ukrainian
sailors detained on Sunday when Russia seized
three vessels off the Crimean coast.
Captured sailors appeared in a Russian court,
and were charged with unlawfully entering
the country, carrying weapons.
They face up to six years in jail.
Earlier other sailors were shown on Russian
television, saying they had deliberately entered
Russian waters as a provocation.
Kiev denounced what it described as forced
confessions
Moscow accuses Kyiv of sparking the sea skirmish
to boost support ahead of an election.
Most probably this provocation took place
in order to achieve certain political decisions
which are beneficial for the current President
of Ukraine."
Ukraine accuses Russia of illegally capturing
its ships and sailors off the coast of Crimea.
President Petro Poroshenko now claims Moscow
is preparing for an invasion.
Together with the country's parliament, he
has imposed martial law in the regions bordering
Russia for 30 days.
"Fundamentally the whole martial law is about
getting resources together and for everybody
here in Ukraine to understand his or her place
when the Russians come further."
President Poroshenko insisted the measures
won't interfere with elections scheduled for
March.
But his decree is causing concern and confusion
in the capital Kyiv.
For Ukrainians, it's unclear what changes
martial law will bring.
After a four-year stand-off with Russia, peace
seems
a distant outcome.